hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor and today we're going to talk
about bacterial ph requirements so let's
go ahead and get started
virtually all bacteria are subject to
various pH requirements what we mean by
this is that all bacteria have some kind
of maximum growth pH and this refers to
the highest pH at which they can still
grow they also have a minimum growth pH
so that would be the lowest pH at which
they can grow and also all bacteria are
going to have an optimum growth pH this
optimum growth pH is where they are
going to grow the best we can actually
classify bacteria based on these pH
requirements and they fall into three
main groups so here on this graph on the
y-axis we have the growth rate higher up
will be the optimum growth so the
optimum growth for the optimum growth
for this group is here optimum growth
for this group is here optimum growth
for this group is here and the maximums
and the minimums would be at either end
back curve so the first group of
bacteria that we can classify based on
pH requirements are those that have an
optimum at ph of 5.5 or less remember
that 7 is neutral anything less than
that is acidic anything greater than
that is basic so when there's an optimum
that's either or 5 and a half or even
lower these are bacteria that we call
acidophiles so they are acid-loving and
they have the ability to thrive at the
lower PHS the next group are the ones
that have optimum growth pH is between
5.5 and 8 so right around that sort of
pH of 7 that's neutral so these are
bacteria that we call nutri vials
and then finally we have the bacteria
that have optimum PHS of 8 or more so
basic PHS remember that alkaline is
another name for basic and so these are
what we call Al kala files and again
different bacteria fall into these
different groups so for example most eco
lion Salmonella are actually neutral
files but the pathogenic strains the
ones that can get into our
gastrointestinal tracts and cost food
poisoning those tend to be acidophiles
because they are better equipped to to
survive and to replicate and grow in the
acidic conditions of the human stomach
some other examples of acidophiles are
lactobacilli lactobacilli are bacteria
that live in the female vagina and
actually create an unproduced lactic
acid lowering the pH of the vagina to
about 4 and this actually means that
they can grow very well but a lot of
other pathogenic bacteria and certain
kinds of pathogenic yeasts cannot grow
at that low pH and thus that protects
women from having things like East
infections an excuse me an example of an
al khaimah file something that's got an
optimum growth pH of 8 or greater is
Vibrio cholerae which causes cholera and
that's why cholera has such a high
infectious dose so for example we have
to ingest something on the order of a
hundred thousand of the Vibrio cholerae
bacteria in order to actually get
cholera and that's because they really
thrive more at this at this higher pH
and so when we ingest them they're no
longer at their
like optimal growth pH it takes quite a
larger dose to actually is sick with
that particular type of bacterium so
that's it today for bacteria pH
requirements you can also check out my
videos on bacteria temperature
requirements bacteria oxygen
requirements and bacteria binary fission
and and growth patterns so check those
out and thanks for watching biology
professor